Olha só essa notícia que acabou de sair
de Harvard. Será que você precisa mesmo
caminhar 10.000 passos por dia para
proteger o seu cérebro do Alzheimer?
Pois é, a resposta vai te surpreender.
Os pesquisadores de Harvard acompanharam
adultos mais velhos durante anos
descobriram algo bem interessante. Eles
focaram em pessoas que já tinham acúmulo
de betamide no cérebro, que é aquela
proteína problemática que aparece antes
dos sintomas de Alzheimer. E sabe o que
descobriram? que caminhar apenas 3 a
5.000 passos por dia, já retardo o
declínio cognitivo em até 3 anos. E se
você caminhar entre 5 e 7.000 passos, o
benefício é ainda maior, pode atrasar os
sintomas em até 7 anos. Veja bem, mesmo
com a betamilóide se acumulando, o
exercício consegue frear o acúmulo da
proteína tal, que é a que realmente
causa os sintomas. Ou seja, seu cérebro
fica protegido mesmo quando você já tem
fatores de risco. E aquela história dos
10.000 passos não tem base científica
sólida e pode até desencorajar quem acha
que é muito, mas eu sinceramente
recomendaria, se você consegue fazer
7.000, aumentasse os seus passos. Mas
comece com 3.000 passos por dia e vá
aumentando conforme puder.